let's talk about this story from the
post-millennial reporters confront White
House Press Secretary after Biden
announces border wall breaking campaign
promise I love this because apparently
Joe Biden is claiming the wall doesn't
work and he has no choice but but to
build it and then you had uh who was it
was it uh um was it blinkin so uh
someone in the Biden admin came out and
now they're like well we got to have a
wall I'll tell you what you're seeing
right here with this story Joe Biden is
violating Federal what he broke 24 26
laws or something like that
federal laws in South Texas to allow the
border wall construction now I got to
say like based Joe Biden here here
here's what happens all these Democrats
are crying their eyeballs out and now
Joe Biden has no choice but to act this
is the kind of thing that spikes them in
2024 you the the Republicans are going
to play every video of every Democrat
saying let them come bring open the
borders and then we got to close the
borders oh gez and they're going to say
don't vote for people who are too stupid
to realize that opening the Border
causes problems yeah Trump wanted 5
billion to build the wall New York just
spent 10 billion to house migrants like
and this stuff is so aggravating because
the media will never tell the truth
about this remember the kids in cages
and all these things like Trump was the
Tyrant at the border this dude now
recognizes the you know pile that he's
laying in here and he's trying to make
the wise decision finally and the media
will never report it he's still the
compassionate one I feel bad for uh uh
Jean Pierre because she's not really
good at this job dude and it's a really
difficult moment to have the the
president flip-flop so heavily how do
you answer that question like even a
seasoned you know press person is going
to be like this is going to be a
challenge we're going to have to figure
out a good answer for this one because
it anybody with eyes is going to be like
as soon as Democrats got mad you guys
turned around and flipped on this she
has no good answer I mean Trump built
almost 500 miles of wall with just
incredible push back the Democrats did
everything they possibly could to stunt
this wall like from being built and he
still got 500 Miles built one of my
favorite stories about how the Democrats
tried stopping the wall was they funded
this uh butterfly migration organization
that sued the Trump administration
because they couldn't let Mexican
butterflies fly into the country and
they successfully halted the wall for
like 7 months8 months and it went all
the way up to you know some some federal
court and
they ended up losing but they used the
butterflies to stop Trump from building
the wall for a
while yeah really pisses me off what's
interesting is I'm from San Diego the
wall works amazingly there it has
transformed the city you know San Diego
is one of the hubs one of the most
primary hubs in the world for sex
trafficking and uh it's sad what happens
in San Diego uh the wall has been a
major deterrent of all of that like it's
it's fortified it is actually secur
and what it does too is it forces a lot
of migrants if they're still going to
try to come into San Diego they go via
water but the waterways in San Diego if
You' ever been massive Cliffs it's very
hard to get access to the land so
they've created this really impenetrable
system and you know who's most grateful
for it when I was in San Diego last
living there uh my community was
majority Hispanic the people the legal
Mexican immigrants were the most
thankful for the wall they're like we
came we came the right way they should
have to come the right way they should
be able to do this we recently went down
to Tijuana and uh when I was down there
I was in an Uber and the Uber driver was
telling us this story and it was kind of
amazing to be told this by an Uber
driver in Mexico he said that he lived
for like two decades in the United
States his mom got sick so he came home
to see her but then he couldn't get back
in the country cuz he had overstate his
Visa he was staying illegally when he
was there and so he worked with human
traffickers he literally said human
traffickers and they threw up a ladder
where he climbed 40 feet up or whatever
to this massive wall near uh near San
Diego and then when the border patrol
agents were coming they panicked pulled
the ladder and ran and left them up
there and he fell down and broke his
legs or whatever and he got he fell back
on the other side and I'm just like it
is insane that this these people feel
like they can just openly say these
things about how they're trying to come
into the United States breaking our laws
but the other crazy thing is the story
is he's basically saying the wall kept
me out wow you
know works but bid's recognizing it's
working how many federal things did he
wave in order to do this you say 26 26
federal laws in South Texas well Biden
is now losing to Trump in 10 of the 11
polls that the real clear politics
average counts and uh one of the major
issues is immigration and Trump beats
Biden on immigration 52 to 28 and so you
know the people are sick of what's
happening at the border and Joe Biden
recognizes it's going to be an absolute
bloodbath for them and the Democrats in
2024 if they don't at least pretend to
address this right right now the polls
that have Biden up are the outliers so
if you do a poll and you find Joe Biden
is ahead you should if you are
responsible report to your audience this
must be an anomalous poll so when the
ABC Washington Post poll came out with
10 with Trump up 10 points they said
this is clearly an outlier it's it's a
blip ignore it ignore it it's like well
you know fair point it is 10 points is a
big heavy swing a lot of ties and Trump
seems to be winning more than he's
losing so at this point if we're going
to hold up that same standard with Biden
according to yugov up five that's an
outlier we shouldn't we should consider
it to be incorrect because Trump's
actually winning almost every other poll
yeah and the Democrats know this uh you
can tell because they've arrested Trump
four times uh and they're changing their
toe on immigration well you see you know
what they're doing now with with the
fraud lawsuit they I I I I believe they
will seize as much of Trump's assets as
possible with this method they can't
just come out and strip Trump of his net
worth of his of the things he owns
because then you know there's going to
be questions about whether or not we
actually live in a country anymore but
here's what we've seen so far with the
judge the judge summarily decrees
without hearing any evidence and
rejecting actual evidence proving Trump
was innocent and says the Trump
organization overvalued its properties
Mara Lago is only worth $18 million
you've got real estate developers and
investors in Florida who are not
Republican and not political scoffing
and complaining be like what do you
think you're doing that's not true our
property is worth a lot of money and so
here's what happens right now the trial
that Trump is facing is to determine
whether or not he falsified business
records if the judge has already
summarily decreed with no legal basis
that Trump's properties are not actually
worth what the bank claimed and what he
claimed and the appraisers claimed it's
kind of a bold thing for someone to do
but the judge said no no no I'm the one
who's going to determine what your
property is worth it's only 10 million
not 100 million okay now they're going
to go to court and and Trump's going to
be like here here are the documents and
the judge is going to go that document
says the building's worth 100 million
but we've already determined it's only
worth 10 million that means you
falsified a document guilty you are
hereby liable for fraud against the
state of New York and you now owe us
$250 million we'll start by seizing that
gigantic Tower that's only worth $10
million you see what they're doing by
claiming maral Lago is worthless when
they file to seize Trump's assets
because he owes them $250 million
they're going to used that to sees
everything that's the game so I think
the next move they'll make is we will
hear that Donald Trump is found liable
of fraud because he falsified records
he'll he'll owe the state or or some you
know regulatory firm or whatever $250
million because it's latia James was
filing the suit then they're going to
seize a a $500 million property but
claim it's worth $10 million and say
okay now you owe us another $240 and
they'll keep doing it until Trump has
nothing left it's sick what's happening
and there's there's no no jury in this
case it is a Democrat activist judge
who's who smiling in the camera who's a
Democrat it's a complete show and
you know we can't let this we can't let
this stand well I think there's no jury
intentionally I think Trump doesn't want
a jury a New York jury is just going to
rule against you it's a waste of time
it's the Trump team probably knows if
they went for a jury trial they'd end up
losing either way but this time it would
actually cost them you know $30 million
in in a legal battle their attitude
probably right now is the judge has has
actually done Trump a favor with the
summary judgment because now Trump is
going to appeal he's been planning to
appeal he needs to get it outside of you
know of of New York City basically and
that's where his actual chance of
winning is going to be don't waste time
and money with a jury trial let the
judge say what he says and then you can
appeal and the judge made the mistake of
being a and saying I'm going to
summary judgment Mar was worthless yeah
now Trump's got all of the all the room
to appeal and be like there is no sane
reasonable human who thinks it's fraud
when the third party when the external
party that you're doing a deal with has
determined the value for you they're
claiming it's fraud that Donald Trump
had that that TR Donald Trump bought a
property or that he found a property
went to a bank and he said to the bank I
want to buy this property the bank sends
at a third party appraiser who then says
to the bank it's worth you know $100
million and then Trump goes you got it
they that's fraud what it if if you come
out and reject the the the appraisal
from the appraiser third party and like
submit separate documents and like
falsified documents okay there's a
question if they want to come out make
those claims sure but for the time being
the judge has rejected any hearing based
on the facts and the Trump organization
says they have testimony from their
lenders who are thanking like they're
saying they made us a lot of money it
was a good deal $40 million in interest
the banks got yeah well and like a
appraisals are helpful but still at the
end of the day real estate is worth
whatever anybody's willing to pay for it
and nobody with their right mind would
say that Mara laga would be sold for $18
million today it's 28 Acres beautiful
real estate 17.5 sorry 17.5 and right on
the ocean has Lake access it's both
ocean access I I just learn it's got a
tunnel under the road yeah to get out to
the beach club wow I learned this I
learned this we learned this from L
Trump the other day Mara laga I I'm such
an idiot it literally means from the
ocean to the to the Lagoon yeah and I
was like oh duh Mar a Lago ocean to
Lagoon a property a property right down
the road just their land I think sold
for like $400 million just a bunch of
trees oh dude like 30.3 acres is 10 510
million Ken Griffin bought a similar lot
the size of marago for about 400 or500
million and so just the lot alone is
worth hundreds of millions of dollars on
top of that marago is a functioning
profitable business and so like who made
the affirmative action attorney general
a real estate expert overnight like
she's clueless and I'm glad she was dumb
enough to post this you know like
campaign style graphic on her Twitter
account she's getting ratioed into
Oblivion I think there's like 14,000
comments on it saying that she's an
idiot which she is thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 800 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net